now last week the BBC quite rightly
lavished unstinting praise and boundless
coverage on the commemorative services
for the d-day landings at Normandy the
sense of reverence even or was palpable
just days later as those same veterans
got home the BBC had a surprise for them
the days of free TV licences were over
all but the poorest 75 year old and
above will be stripped of the perk
they've enjoyed for nearly 20 years as
the corporation pleaded poverty and said
it was the only way to make 500 million
pounds worth of cuts required save for
closing a raft of TV or radio stations
well that excuses just be being nonsense
here's where savings could be made an 87
million pound new set for EastEnders
that's mere vanity the 1 billion pound
new london HQ that was censored for
being a hundred and seven million pounds
over budget and the 2,700 staff we've
got pay rises of over 10% the BBC used
to be nicknamed auntie Greta bleah it is
now more like a money-grubbing relative
trying to bump off grandad nakai I think
you've missed the whole point of the
slap the point of it is this is a
government there was a government
decision which the BBC called a good
deal upon signing Greg the BBC said this
is a good deal less than five years
because government now they're charged
let's go back the government tried to do
this twice the first time they try to do
it the Director General and the Chairman
both threatened to resign if they did it
and it disappeared the second time they
did it they didn't do it now the
government must have known must have
known that the BBC would do exactly what
they've done that they would look after
the law all of three to resign I oh yes
at the time yes I think nordhal and the
chairman of the BBC and the BBC
government then should have said we're
not doing this we are not appointed as
governors of the BBC to decide social
policy in this country that's what
you're elected for that's what you're
there for and I think to see the Prime
Minister this week saying the BBC
done the wrong thing it's her fault it's
their fault they shouldn't do the how
the BBC I mean you've gone through a
list of there's tons more which I score
yeah but there are many more but but
it's they're nothing like the scale of
the money that's gonna be would have
been lost I mean 20 percent of all the
money that would have gone to the BBC
would have been in favor of this even
though they had no choice no but they
did sign off on the deal they do the
good deal gave them the right to make
the decision they made this week Rachel
I think the BBC's done exactly the right
thing I can't understand I mean why
bring d-day veterans into this poor
souls were going to say sadly there are
very few of those that makes it alright
they're behaving and I'm hope that if
they want to claim pension credit they
should get their free TV licence but
what the BBC have absolutely no option
we are in an aging society where the
rich are disproportionately richer than
than the young oh babe why should
generation rent subsidize the baby
boomers who have can easily afford 150
pounds 50 or different one lakh behind
it and all the other broadcasters who
obviously quite rightly and resent the
the licence what's it because arguably
it is an it is attached to the context
the BBC has got to look at the whole
subscription model what we've got to do
is get rid of the licence for you moved
to a proper subscription model but while
we have the licence fee it's only fair
we've got to bust this myth that own
people are wealthy now there's a very
small percentage of old people that that
have money a third of all let me finish
like you just had a lot like me a third
of all pensioners in this country
depends solely on the state pension the
Joseph Rowntree Foundation did a report
last year one in six pensioners in this
country live in poverty that's a 33%
increase if they can't do it
you know they can't maybe they were on
pretty credit no pension credits on
massively under claimed and you ought to
know that and
massively undeclared because a lot of
young people are about people live on
their own no let me finish they don't
have to do it they're madly yes under
can I just say something and then we ask
it Junior Rachel I talked to a BBC
somebody who actually was part of the
decision to charge pensioners again and
he said part of the problem is is that
the government is actually going to have
to pay the cost because so many
pensioners are now going to charge
pension credit and so the whole thing is
going to devolve back to taxpayer - I
just think we're forgetting the humanity
of this whole thing you know for a lot
of old people that are on their own the
beep you see on television is there and
radio is their only access to the
outside world and you know what you're
talking about the baby boomers having
money and so on
I think they've earned it you know what
if you've lived for 75 years if you've
paid into the system I'm sorry you
deserve to have that was the decision
that the Labour government took when
they first gave free licenses which is
fine that was fine if they want even if
it was a government an elected
government's decision that they wanted
to older people over something you have
to have a Fenian license fine yes
what they then did is push this to the
governors of the BBC and said you've got
to make that decision
well then we're never to begin to make
seriously going to start prosecuting 80
and 90 year olds in and we drill down it
who did look at the benefits for the old
order remember from bus passes to winter
fuel ads electoral bribes to the older
voters who like to go through the TV
listings great day the BBC One's budget
is over 1 billion pounds BBC Two's is
just under 400 so that's 1.5 billion
pounds now what have we got on oh here
we are a repeat at 11 o'clock BBC one a
ones Britain's along this road followed
by court red-handed a repeat it's all
repeats if I paid my TV license last
year I forget the [ __ ]
can I bring it
can I bring in a clip from top what Tom
Watson cuz I think what the point he
makes is totally spot-on in terms of the
Tory government and how they renamed on
their promise the government made a
solemn promise to three million
pensioners that they wouldn't do this in
their manifesto in 2017 they said they
would guarantee the free TV license for
the duration of this Parliament until
2022 so this represents not just a
diwali see that's responded that central
government should be dealing with but
it's also a betrayal of pensioners and
represents a lie in the last Tory
manifesto I think they've been let down
both by the government and by the
governor's they should resign we do we
did ask the BBC to comment as we must
and they came in in response to your
intro good they say one the set of
EastEnders was built in 1984 and only
intended for use for two years over 30
years later the show remains one of the
BBC's flagship programmes and yet it's
filming from a set that is no longer fit
for purpose they then say serious
mistakes were made in the first phase of
the Paul Pott Broadcasting House project
licence fee payers were let down and
finally they say and while there are
strict rules about any pay increases
it's only right that when people are
promoted or take on extra
responsibilities it's reflected in their
salaries I love the fact that you've
read that firstly you don't have to
sanction it okay yes they had to have a
new set but the original budget was
barely fifty two million and it ended up
in 87 billion but the point is their
annual budget is 5 billion 2.4 billion
of that goes on programming the rest
goes on admin management and salaries
and pensions and that's where they need
to put their house in order that can
make the savings they need their pension
scheme has was dramatically changed at
least 50 billion pounds black hole 200
million pound a year they'll have to go
but don't worry we'll tax 90 year old
asset that's almost
pension fund in this cow like that if
you measure it in a certain way yeah but
that night you that 90 year old can't
watch telly or listen to the radio
unless he or she has a licence that's
what shot in the foot because you know
it's a known goal by the BBC q90 there's
the majority of their audience the
reality is they they took this decision
three years ago they and the government
or four years ago and it was a mistake
thank you it was a mistake they should
have said to the government we're not we
cannot make we as the governors of the
BBC cannot make this sort of decision
that's what you're in and